Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une partie de pêche à l'aimant
On est en compagnie du stagiaire
Qui est de retour
Et surtout de Fabrice: "Les aimants cools"
Avec Aymeric
On a fait des petites trouvailles déjà, regardez un sac
Regardez ce qu'ils ont déjà trouvé
Carte vitale, carte d'identité
On floutera le nom
Carte bleu, permis aussi
Ils sont périmés ?
Non je ne pense pas, faut regarder
Il y avait deux sacs
Regardez la calculatrice, a mon avis c'était une entreprise
Oui oui clairement
Qu'est ce qu'il y a d'autre ? On a regardé rapidement seulement
Un stylo
Trousseau de clefs
Vraiment énorme, comme des clefs d'entreprise
On est à un petit spot, on a déjà fait un coffre fort
Aymeric a sorti une barque on mettra la vidéo
On la mettra en description quand la vidéo sortira
C'est un spot avec un petit ruisseau
Tout petit mais qui réserve pas mal de surprises
Petite mise à jour avant d'attaquer la pêche à l'aimant
Fabrice a réussi à retrouver la propriétaire de ce sac à main
Elle a été victime d'une agression assez violente il y a quelque mois
On lui a dérobé ce sac et une importante somme d'argent
Il a réussi à la retrouver pour lui restituer les papiers qu'elle n'avait pas encore fait refaire
Et ce qui était dans le sac et pouvait encore l'intéresser
Première trouvaille de la journée pour le stagiaire
Petit couteau pour le barbecue de demain
Est-ce que c'est un vrai Laguiole ? Non
Il est neuf en tout cas
Bien joué. Il y a un petit paquet de chips aussi
Belle dépollution ça
Envoies par derrière
Par derrière et tu ramènes vers là
On le soulève
C'est lourd
Attend j'ai encore un truc, ce n'est pas ça
Ca vient ! C'est plus lourd, il y a autre chose
C'est lourd, on a besoin de toi Antoine
C'est un coffre fort !
Pas sûr
Viens Antoine, avec ton aimant
On essaie de le monter là
C'est un beau bébé
Essaies de coincer ton aimant dedans
Il a cassé
Le coffre il fini en morceau
Il est tellement vieux qu'on arrache des morceaux de coffre
Premier quart d'heure de pêche, il se fait mal au dos
Oh la clef de coffre ! C'est bon signe, elle est énorme
Elle est magnifique, en laiton
Incroyable, c'est Mickey !
C'est collector
Là regardez, petite trottinette
Sympa
Il manque la roue avant, dommage
Trouvaille cool
Et là un piège à poisson, en bon état, une nasse
Oh ! Les abrutis
Je vais essayer de descendre, attends
On va essayer de le faire basculer à la main
Ok c'est bon on est posé dessus là
Bien joué les gars
Bravo, joli coffre
Bravo à tous, il est d'époque
Tu vois, première pêche qu'on fait ensemble, directement du lourd
Bien joué Rasta aussi
Il n'y a pas un arrière fond ? Il y a une plaque
Une moule
Il n'y a rien d'autre dedans
Mais ouais la clef est vraiment belle
C'est une roue
Il y a la jante avec
Ramenez le là bas, se sera plus facile pour le prendre
Il est là Rasta
Pas mal
Regardez ce que j'ai sorti, un classique
De ça il y en a partout
Un couteau
Couteau rond
Ah non pas rond
Une bouteille de gaz ou je ne sais pas quoi
Boule de pétanque, je vais la coincer comme ça
Regardez, c'est Antoine
Fourchette
Oh t'as un couteau
Il y en a plein ici
C'est fou le nombre de couteaux qu'on a fait
Il est en bon état, ouais j'ai fais le même a peu prêt
Ah, j'ai quelque chose
Oh c'est un sac non ?
Un très vieux sac
C'est du vieux plastique
On va voir si il reste des choses dedans
Il n'y a rien
Ah si, il y a un pendentif
On dirait un vieux pendentif
Ici, il a un truc
Ca peut être un coffre
Mais c'est dans la vase
Alors Antoine ? - Que des algues
Et Rasta, qu'est ce que tu en penses ?
On est dessus là ?
On tire ?
Beurk ! Elle est bonne l'eau ...
Là ça vient !
Il y a un truc qui vient !
Génial ! Regardez
Ca c'est la classe les gars !
Ouah la vase !
La quantité de vase qu'il y a
Il y a des papiers
C'est bon ça
Ca c'est du cuir, on voit que c'est de la qualité
Regardez ça
Il y a des documents qui sont abimés
Oh ! C'est un endroit ou on mets les pièces de monnaie
Des pièces de collection, ça aurait été cool. Il en reste peut être au fond
Il y a un truc encore, regardes, une ceinture
Avec une sangle
C'était une attache pour une valisette je pense
Elle a totalement fondu
Là j'ai quelque chose de rigide à l'intérieur
Il y a des choses encore
C'était des pochettes de pièces encore
Ca devait être une collection de pièces
Oh, regardes !
10centimes
Oh ! C'est un portable
Ah oui ! Trop bien !
C'est le portable des voleurs ça
Regardes, Nokia
C'est une batterie ça. Ils ont enlevé la carte SIM
Elle est là la batterie
Il doit encore marcher
Regardez, il y a des inscriptions là
Rinces ça un coup
Ouais, il y a écrit des trucs là dessus
Il y a écrit : "pièces 1 euro, 2 euros"
La coque du portable
Génial
Restauration !
Ils n'ont pas laissés de pièces on dirait. - Mais si il y en avait une là, 1 centime.
C'est peut être un centime collector
Ah les gars, je crois que j'ai des cartes
Je vais les rincer
2007, c'est pas très vieux
Ah, expire en 2014
J'étais pas loin
Si elle périme en 2014, ca veut dire que c'est un vole de 2012, 2013
Regardez
Des belles petites clefs en laiton, génial
Bah voilà, super on a eu le coffre
Bon, tu as trouvé quelque chose dans le rinçage ?
Elle est comme aimanté au coffre, elle ne sort pas
Ah oui d'accord, elle est collé
La carte bleu !
Expire en 2012 celle là, alors c'était peut être même avant 2012
C'est vieux !
Sympa
Ca vient
Oh les gars, venez nous aider
Une bécane
Ou un vélo
Si le vélo nous parait lourd comme ça, c'est à cause la vase
Beau petit vélo, bien joué
Un BMX ?
BMX ou vélo pour enfant ?
C'est un VTT ça
Regarde la taille de la roue avant par rapport à la roue arrière
C'est dommage l'eau est peu salé ici, regarde comme elle mange le métal
Mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ? La différence de taille de roue !
Je ne suis pas un peu sale ?
Bah ! Tu ne montes pas dans la voiture comme ça
J'irai me baigner avant
Tu te mettras en caleçon pour aller faire les courses
On enverra le stagiaire, il est encore propre
Oh non
On va se baigner dans la mer d'abord
Non dans le fleuve Hérault ! - Pas l'Hérault Quentin !
Pas les roux
Bon, j'arrête de filmer, vous êtes trop long
Les anguilles ?
Le Fer !
Ah !
C'est des aimants
Il t'as traités d'anguilles, Antoine
Il a dit que tu étais une anguille
Je l'ai enfin eu, après plus d'un quart d'heure de persévérance
Pour moi c'est, un cadre de moto
Un coffre fort !
Oh non ! Le bord
On a perdu un aimant
Il a raison, faut l'attraper
Il est ouvert, oh non
Ca va il y a la porte pour bloquer les trucs.
Alors, Unboxing !
On va le vider
Génial l'état de la route
je crois que la route c'est déjà mort !
ça c'est quoi une pile ?
regarde j'ai trouvé ça moi
Piles électriques de coffres forts
C'est des plombs ?
"Gevelots"
A ton avis ?
C'est des plombs ?
Super
C'est du plomb ou du 6mm bosquet ?
Ah oui d'accord, mais c'est trop cool !
Il y a peut-être une carabine là où tu étais
C'était là bas ?
En général ça va avec un petit pistolet de salon ou une petite carabine
est-ce que ça ne serait pas encore un coffre fort ?
Ah non
Ah une roue de vélo !
Elle n'est pas jeune
Les gars on fait quoi ce soir ?
Oh un gyrophare !
C'est trop bien !
Bleu en plus !
Ouais
C'est un gyrophare de la police ça
Un gyrophare de police
Ah il y a le câble !
Ne le casse pas
Tu imagines si il marche ?
C'est trop bien
j'adore
ça c'est cool !
C'est quand ils volent les voitures en se faisant passer pour la police ça !
Clairement je vais le mettre sur L'opel Vectra d'office !
On va voir si l'aimant marche encore
Pour quand on ira en intervention de pêche à l'aimant
Il n'est pas vieux
Ah ça accroche bien !
Voilà, il est en place
Notre équipe de journalistes accompagne la brigade d'intervention des pêcheurs à l'aimant
Ce ne sont pas les couteaux les plus affutés du tirroir
Mais ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
C'est une brigade très spéciale
il marche mal là !
Quelques secondes plus tard, le gyrophare nous a lâché.
N'hésitez pas à déposer votre pouce bleu sous cette vidéo pour soutenir ce pauvre gyrophare
Ah non
Tu m'aides à tirer d'un coup sec ?
un morceau de chaise ou quoi ?
Ouais pas grand chose d'intéresant
Un autoradio
Lecteur de cassettes ?
Comme il a l'air vieux ! Tu as les fréquences
Il est vintage et bien conservé
On le met dans l'Opel Vectra celui-là ou pas ?
Ouais il est beau
Moi j'ai quelque chose là
C'est quoi ça ? Un cadre de scooter
j'ai des pièces de monnaie avec sur l'aimant
Tu as un cintre aussi
Super
Il n'est pas jeune ce cadre de mobylette
Ce n'est pas une pièce de monnaie
C'est nul...
Okay
Comme dirait Naps
Je dois faire une déclaration
On a toujours pas mangé
Si l'équipe de l'inspection du travail passe par ici
J'aimerais qu'il y ait une petite intervention sur ce stage
car ça ne va pas du tout
Extincteur ou grenade ?
Extincteur
C'est bien une goupille d'extincteur
T'as raison Antoine c'est un extincteur
Je suis déçus
ça ne tombe pas
Vous faîtes quoi ?
La ferraille !
Vous avez trouvé des cadres de scooter ? Il y en a un par là
C'est peut-être ça, il y a un truc là qui ne vient pas
Juste là ?
Non au fond au milieu là
Vous faites des vidéos sur YouTube ?
Ouais
C'est quoi la chaîne ?
C'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Là on a fait un petit couteau, une fusée de détresse
C'est sympa ça
Il y a les bords d'une valise
Le couteau est joli
Palares Solsola Inox
Une fois on a repêché une fusée de détresse qui a fonctionné
Mais beaucoup de personnes nous ont dit que c'était dangereux
Donc on ne va plus le refaire
Ici ils ont jeté des médicaments ?
Grenade ?
Woaw !
Belle trouvaille des aimants cools !
Non dégoupillée, fonctionnelle
Grenade bleue, donc à plâtre (entraînement)
Il y a quand même une charge dans le détonateur mais juste assez pour la faire exploser
Par contre elle a l'air toute dévissée toute bizarre
C'est pas normal que ça bouge comme ça
Une fois on a croisé un mec qui pêchait à l'aimant quand en a trouvé une et il a appelé les gendarmes
Il lui ont demandé la couleur de la grenade
Ils lui ont dit dégoupille la et jette la
Mais bon je pense que l'on ne vas pas s'y risquer là
ça fait quand même peur
Mais ouais belle trouvaille, sympa
Bravo l'aimant cool, super
C'est toujours impressionnant de voir une grenade, rien qu'avec sa forme
Si il y a ça, il peut y avoir n'importe quoi ici
Du coup là mauvaise nouvelle
En plus le treuil est super lourd
Il est ou le serpent ?
Il faut tout sortir
Il est sous le treuil, sous le carton
Si c'est un orvet ça va
C'est possible que ce soit un orvet mais c'est pas sûr
Un orvet dans le sud c'est rare
On en a déjà vu mais là le serpent est grand quand même
Au bord de l'eau ça peut-être une vipère
Il fait 30 à 40 centimètres
Quelle couleur ? Gris ?
Plutôt gris oui
un orvet c'est couleur chromée
Recul Aymeric
Là il est vraiment gris-marron
Le serpent était sûrement dans ce sac
Ah dans ce sac là bas ?
Nos gants ne protègent pas assez en plus
On remet tout à l'eau là ?
Ahaha ouais ouais
Il faudrait un truc pour bloquer le serpent
Ouais, tu l'as vu ?
Où ?
Dans le carton ?
Ah oui il est là
C'est une vipère ça
Ah oui c'est dangereux, c'est bien une vipère
Attends il pèse 40kg le treuil
Il ne va pas venir avec le carton le treuil
Attention à vous les gars
Ne bougez pas bougez pas
Lâche lâche
Lâche le lâche le
Y a le chien !
Non mais vous êtes sérieux là ?
T'inquiètes, elle est là
Rentre le chien
Viens là viens là
Fou le dedans lui
Elle est partie là bas ?
Laisse là on ne va pas la tuer
Non non je lui fais peur
C'est mortel ça
Allez
Ok mission de sauvetage réussie
T'as vu comme il est balaise
La vidéo de pêche à l'aimant touche à sa fin
Du très très lourd encore une fois
Dans ce coin
Bravo aux aimants cools pour le spot
On a remonté un super gros coffre, deux petits ici...
C'est toujours un plaisir avec pêcheur de Trésors
On sait que ça va ramener du lourd
A la prochaine, pensez à vous abonner !